que ça te plaise ou non
tu es maintenant un super-héros
très bon j'essaie juste de te montrer non
j'ai fini on m'a montré je n'ai pas fait d'
école de droit pour devenir justicier
[Applaudissements]
notre univers est sur le  bord d'un
précipice d'accord faisons ça
qui diable es-tu
ce nom vaut mieux ne pas coller
avocat uniquement sur disney plus
parce qu'être un super-héros est un procès par le
feu
bruce je ne vais pas être un super-héros quoi d'
autre tu vas  faire comme un hulk
[Applaudissements]
avocat
nous venons de créer une
division de droit surhumain et je veux que la hulk soit
la confrontation
nous faisons les choses selon le livre le livre de son
chant le livre de la
perte américaine euh
[Musique]
être un  hulk demande l'équilibre
c'est facile
petit punk
donc je suis clairement en train de le clouer à toutes ces
choses quand vais-je un jour utiliser ça
comme avocat jen quand tu as des pouvoirs
comme ça c'est comme mettre une cible sur
ton dos dans le  dans le dos de toutes les personnes
qui comptent pour toi oh cool encore une autre façon de
gérer ma vie merci bruce d'accord d'
accord  que j'ai fait est de vous montrer les
inconvénients d'être un hulk, mais il y
a quelques avantages que
notre corps métabolise l'alcool à un
rythme incroyablement rapide,
ce qui signifie
que nous pouvons boire autant et ne pas nous
saouler tout le monde ne vomit
pas c'est bon
toi